I'm Will Arnett and today I'm doing the
wired complete interview the wired the
wired autocomplete interview see it
should have auto-completed my intro is
Will Arnett try to guess at home or work
I don't know where you're watching this
I don't know your life is Will Arnett
Canadian Will Arnett as Canadian born is
Will Arnett related to Michael Keenan
why is that like something that comes up
blood he's not I can speak for him for
Will Arnett I can't speak for Michael
Keaton is Will Arnett in
Skyrim I don't know did you know it's
diamonds I don't how much is Will Arnett
worth he's worth all the love in your
heart I do like this is just gonna get
worse by the way this is just gonna get
meaner and meaner does Will Arnett
sometimes have siblings
yes Will Arnett has three siblings that
he loves very much and has not talked to
in 12 you can tell here they won't talk
to him does will earn it have a son I
have two sons who does Will Arnett think
he is look like I'll give you a him
alone Liz slurs breakfast-table another
one any better it's fun to talk about
will in this third dress way isn't it
and it's great to have him here - oh did
Will Arnett get my number get famous the
age-old way clawing and scratching how
tall is Will Arnett in feet like a
child's feet he's like a hundred child's
look
children's feeds how does Will Arnett
live with himself through tears I just
will arnett stay in shape great question
how long you got it starts off with a
balanced breakfast I get 11 and a half
hours of sleep at night I don't know he
just he doesn't how to contact Will
Arnett you don't you don't contact learn
it plus you don't want to wear wear is
we learn it from from Toronto that's the
truth where did Will Arnett learn to be
such a jerk go to high school where did
he go to high school he went to a couple
different places because I like variety
sometimes I'd be in one school and
they'd say Will Arnett you're an
acquired taste and we don't like it it
spit me huh where did Will Arnett go to
college he dropped out of college but I
don't want to do an endorsement for a
place that I dropped out of in Montreal
school that will remain Concordia where
is will earn it right now well where the
do you think he is right here with
you the one I love the most
honestly this the top of it it's the
questions of the top that get me is Will
Arnett is he is what is Will Arnett's
first film I don't think even think my
character had a name it was a film
called Ed's next move and the first film
that I was like in in was a little super
indie called Erie what is Will Arnett's
first animated film Ice Age - the
hardest part about doing animated stuff
is people don't get to see this and I
feel like they're bumped truthfully it
takes a long time so you're doing it
over a long it's one of the great parts
about it but it also means that you're
you're constantly trying to keep
energized and engaged with with that
story because it does take so long to
tell this one kind of story for me I
have to find kind of new ways in to what
excites me about doing that story
because I have a really short attention
who is that who is Will Arnett's related
to I'm related to my parents related to
my sister's and my kids but I'm not
related to anybody that y'all would know
I don't think but no there was nothing
thanks for asking these questions and
don't be afraid to keep googling me